for as long as I can remember there have
been two people inside my head
whispering to me now I want to introduce
them to you and I think the best way to
do that is with an experience I had last
year in probably my least favorite place
in the entire world the customer service
line at United Airlines
I had gotten to SFO an hour early to
have plenty of time to make my direct
flight to JFK I was looking forward to
landing late that evening and getting a
good night's sleep before my friend's
wedding the following afternoon instead
as I was going through security I got a
text from United saying my flight was
canceled for airplane maintenance I
rushed to the customer service line
where after waiting my turn the woman
behind the counter told me there was no
way I could get to New York before
Sunday my response wait you're telling
me it'll take two days to get from San
Francisco to New York that can't be
right please check again the woman did
not take kindly to my tone and pushed a
few buttons before telling me I could
take a two-layer of a trip and make the
tail end of the reception take it or
leave it
I tried after the fact to be friendly
but couldn't get any other options and I
took it later I found out a friend
behind me in line had patiently managed
to get a one-layer of her trip and make
the ceremony so that's what happened
outside my head out in the world but
here's what happened with those two
people inside my head now the first
person imagine him whispering to me from
my left shoulder I called the eager
updater I got to the airport saw the
cancellation text and the eager updater
chimed right into my head he said hmm
you know it looks like the plane we
expected to take us to New York isn't
going there after all good to know
what's our best option now as I dealt
with the customer service lady the eager
updater immediately noticed she wasn't
the instant Ally I'd been counting on he
said good to know now we can adjust our
approach to get the best outcome from
the woman who is in front
of us and not the woman we thought she'd
be pretty mature right kind of
suspicious though like if the eager
updater was whispering all this useful
stuff to me how come I acted so
ineffectively
well that's where the second person in
my head comes in I call him the king of
wishful thinking imagine him whispering
to me from my right shoulder now the
king of wishful thinking saw the
cancellation text and he too chimed
right into my head he said this
shouldn't be happening
we were just about to be on our way to
New York and now we have to deal with a
frustrating day of travel hassle every
minute I stood in the customer service
line the king of wishful thinking was
whispering reminders to me you know we'd
expected to be in the air by now by now
we'd be over Colorado on our way to a
nice warm hotel room as I dealt with the
customer service lady the king of
wishful thinking said to me if someone
competent was back there we would they
would have fixed this by now this
shouldn't be happening so those are the
two folks whispering in my head all the
time
the eager updater with his various forms
of good to know and the king of wishful
thinking riffing on his awesome
catchphrase this shouldn't be happening
and if these guys are starting to sound
familiar to you they should because
these two characters are whispering in
your head all the time to the eager
updater and the king of wishful thinking
are just two ways our brains are wired
to receive and process information over
the past couple years I've gotten really
interested in the neuroscience and
psychology behind how we handle
situations and I've been starting in
particularly this duality between
perception and expectation I gave names
and personalities to these mental
processes really just to help me more
easily apply what I've learned to begin
to make better decisions in my own life
and I want to share them with you
because I think that getting more
acquainted with these guys in each of
our heads can help us handle be be more
effective in handling a wide variety of
situations we face every day so I think
of the eager updater as
this guy that openly seeks out new
information to update our view of what
is happening in any situation he plugs
into our five senses to add more data so
we can better understand accept and
respond to the real world in which we
operate the king of wishful thinking on
the other hand filters every experience
we have through the lens of our
expectations our hopes our beliefs our
anticipations about what will happen or
what should happen in any situation
now maybe you're having visions right
now of old cartoons with an eager
updater angel on one shoulder and a king
of wishful thinking devil on the other
that's not fair to the king of wishful
thinking we evolved this expectation
lens for very good reasons for one being
able to set a future goal and hold it in
mind keeps us motivated and proactive as
we work to achieve it it also keeps us
mentally efficient allowing us to focus
on just the most relevant parts of our
surroundings the neuroscience research
for example suggests that our eyes
actually use our expectations to fill
out most of what we see with just small
amounts of new data in forming the
picture the problem though is that even
though the king of wishful thinking is
useful and necessary he does have a
tendency to get much louder than our
eager updater and drown him out and
that's what happened with my experience
with United Airlines but this tendency
applies well beyond changing travel
plans so for example an over assertive
king of wishful thinking contributed to
my staying in relationships too long
when I clung to an image of the girl I
hoped I was dating and filtered out the
information in the real world that was
showing me something different or beyond
my own personal experience I was
chatting about this topic last month
with an entrepreneur here in the valley
who immediately recognized the king of
wishful thinking in himself as the
number one reason his first startup
hadn't taken off for one thing he said
he had really wanted all of his early
employees to be high performers and so
didn't acknowledge soon enough that some
of them were not an act
khalida course correct similarly he said
he had expected that the product
offering he'd come up with would be very
difficult to replicate and so wasn't
attentive to the competitors that
started to enter and gain market share
now hopefully each of these experiences
reinforces that our king of wishful
thinking can be allowed and damaging
part of our psychology and our
neurophysiology but that doesn't mean we
just have to throw up our hands the
research suggested are two relatively
simple steps we can take to bring him
more in line and the first step is
simply to recognize that we all have a
king of wishful thinking whispering
inside our heads all the time and be
aware when he might be getting too
dominant
now here the science suggests that there
are five emotions that are the most
useful red flags for this and as I list
them think about a time you've recently
felt these frustration anger jealousy
irritation disappointment recognize
those I know I felt three or four of
them this morning before breakfast well
it turns out that these are signals of
an over aggressive king of wishful
thinking basically telling us that
there's something that we were hoping
for or expecting from reality that isn't
they're basically telling us this
shouldn't be happening the second step
then is in those situations to summon a
more attentive and assertive eager
updater and the main strategy here is to
open out our perceptual field by asking
questions like how might I respond
differently now given the new
information available or by responding
to the Kings this shouldn't be happening
with this is happening good to know with
just these two steps we can change the
way we experience the setbacks and
opportunities in our lives with the
benefit of a more clear sighted and
constructive view of what's going on
around us and that's my hope for myself
and it's my hope for each of you
that next time you're working hard to
solve a complex problem or grow a
promising company or take the next step
in a relationship or heaven forbid
reschedule flight on United I hope you
stop take a mental step back and
readjust the volume settings of the two
companions whispering from your
shoulders